a word pursuit of the snooper PS that's
right part of the PS guy otherwise known
as the piece of shits there he is
sir please pull over oh he's driving
insane pull over
he appears to be launching some sort of
explosives out of the back of his
vehicle
probably homemade sir please pull over
oh my god oh he's subscribe action
perfmon I'm going on foot
so Danny we got some word of a possible
suspect in the these towers here we're
gonna have just question him and see if
he can answer some questions class oh
that's good to stretch your legs it
really is how your kids by the way
don't ask me that okay it ripped pieces
of [ __ ] alright so we're gonna give this
guy a call she got some donuts after
this oh yeah definitely so this is the
LSPD we just like to ask you a few
questions if you don't mind letting us
in we'd like to search your place if
that's okay hey how you doing sir
oh we got a little tip that there's some
cocaine up here
do you mind letting in my fellow officer
please his name's officer O'Dwyer can
you hear me sir thank you sir
s-sir what type of work you do a lot of
nice furnishings oh look at this officer
old wire oh this one don't mind if you
do huh sir do you know it's a felony to
smoke marijuana in the Greater Los
Santos area yeah this is not Colorado I
don't know
punk do you think this is drugs I got to
make sure it sounds like it yeah test
what it is could be a tobacco you better
test it out all right so uh what line of
work are you in sir
yep the stuff Daniel always going right
for the wine this guy likes to live free
be sure guys I'm gonna take a look
downstairs you sounds good so how do you
pay for all this sir you don't talk much
do ya cat got your tongue or is it that
cocaine you've been hiding that is
nothing down here it's just a empty
bedroom what a real piece of [ __ ] you
hide yourself well don't you sir this
guy's got a thing for ladies boots hey
Danny I just saw $7,000 warrant there's
someone to arrest we bet we better get
over the roll the next ride who's
driving you draft well that's it over
there oh my god
this Nupur well well well Snooper
you've just made yourself an enemy of
the law that was our last cop car we
can't get another one of those cop cars
we better
acquisition the civilian vehicle
dispatch this is car 45 we are currently
in a civilian vehicle if you could
please contact the owner of this car and
let them know that we will not be
returning it
could you ask you to put away that
weapon as well that's a put away the
weapon now thank you God [ __ ] get in
the back nut shop and you're not good
enough for shotgun like you sir
all right so you're a friend of the
Purefoy believe my name is officer Dwyer
yeah my name is officer handler I want
to know everything you know about snuke
uh he's a murderer and he killed two of
my best cops that's [ __ ] sir you've
uh you've been interesting accent is
that a British accent
you've been Britain what are you doing
you live in London so you're just here
on holidays oh my here on vacation
suspect is in a plane flying over oh my
god suss you're in wait how are you in
London now have you been smoking the
reefer sir well Danny looks like Snooper
got away in a in a Titan plane indeed
right in front of us I did not see that
coming yeah I did not see that coming
that was like that was a good getaway
I'm not gonna lie we have a different
salient
that's right dispatch just called in
another warrant we're gonna take a look
and see if he's around we also have a
gentleman the back of our cruiser who
believes he is currently in London
England we're gonna bring him in for
psych evaluation pretty soon where are
you originally for you're from focussed
you're from Afghanistan Oh God Chuck
fine we got it well I'm glad you're here
in America now sir look alive guys shot
you uh you handle a weapon pretty good
for an innocent man you got him you
nailed him okay well put that gun away
thank you but put that gun away whoa
our British friends our British Afghan
friend has this uh this perps number
keep up the good work and I might I
might hire you oh here we go
Oh but why are you doing officer I'm
alert good it seemed to me missing your
door so it looks like the suspect is on
the beach trying probably getting a tan
because he's a white pale man
like tail mail I could go for a white
pay ll right now I Amen that sounds
pretty good right now oh this individual
here we need to oh my God he's firing
shut up please
yeah we need to get the hell out of here
too hot this is a real this is dispatch
this is car 76 and this is turning into
a real shitstorm I was looking forward
to getting home talking my kids into bed
telling them daddy's been okay every day
I lied to my kids all over again I tell
them this job isn't dangerous look at
this [ __ ]
it's a frickin tank sir put down the
tank heading north on and we're gonna
need you to pull over
sir please pull over you send the horn
please sir please stop throwing grenades
sir we talked to you all Thomas you son
of a [ __ ] hey Thomas would you get this
truck hi Murray officer I have already
please get back in Thomas you put that
hose away Thomas we may need you
you mean you may want to stay in that
pursuit there Thomas whoa whoa nice nice
driving thank you
Oh a word pursuit of the snooper PS I
drank part of the PS guy otherwise known
as the piece of shits there he is
sir please pull over oh he's driving
insane pull over
he appears to be launching some sort of
explosives out of the back of his
vehicle
probably homemade sir please pull over
oh my god oh he's just crushed he's
driving back per mom I'm going on foot
mrs. Christ I'm trying to I think you
may want to get back in your vehicle
dispatch we are currently on a civilian
walkway across Cyprus Fields bridge the
purpose told us to dick off Thomas you
get you bring that hose with you whoa
take that you piece of [ __ ] I'm on foot
officer idler could you arrest the per
please Thomas hose them post some
comments hose them thank God we have
Thomas there Thomas get it how much
what's going on
you look shell-shocked dispatch thank
you for the army vehicles you said our
way we appreciate it
officers handler erode wire and life are
in pursuit of perp
he's telling us we're clearly dispatch
he is on drugs oh my god it's the
Snooper the Snooper has a bitchin car
Snooper you piece of [ __ ] I'm gonna blow
your head off with your stupid gold car
your pieces die die
be bullets you dick dispatch I'm
currently in pursuit of Snooper PS I'm
bringing it I'm literally shooting at
you right now as as you're trash-talking
me
this is officer handler I got eyes on
the sky snoop has appears to have the
gang leader car for this game spot crew
he's got game spot logos Danny I'm
watching the whole thing they've got
gang signs all over all over his car
this is this is looking real ugly
officer handler you near support I am I
got eyes in the sky things are looking
real ugly out from up here Danny you
hang in there got a Buxton I've got him
boxed in all right you could you watch
the sad side of this you got it
I need to here we go I got him I got him
gotta wait Rob can you pick me up you
got it where are you because that's a
stolen police car I'm gonna need that
officer Adler II I'm in the back tom
wait for Thomas get the Thomas to come
in did you just hear that you do hear II
said to me I believe he called me a
[ __ ] on a police radio that is a
federal offense sir
dad I think you might want to take off
Thomas did you hear that he called me go
to eat a [ __ ] house handler is
it near the end of our shift it sure is
I believe it's a vanilla unicorn break
good to be back in the unicorn ah Danny
I don't know if I can do this anymore
it's been a rough day really ass gonna
go see a lady of the night
and you girls like cups sup smoke Taylor
I just want to say you did a damn good
job if you need me officer Anthony I'll
be in the back sounds good well Danny
spin up one hell of a day it's been a
great day hold on Danny hold on guess we
just showed up ooh Thomas Oh Thomas get
in here we found us thank god I've got
I've got this beautiful girl
I never knew your firemen that EMT stuff
was amazing impressive as always and you
smokes Taylor that's right I'll see you
- all of you - all of you men take care
of one I'm gonna see me some titties